sigh of relief for travelers tonight
because a federal judge voided the
national mass mandate on airplanes and
public transit so that means you are no
longer required to wear a mask when you
travel so this paves a way for airlines
and airports and also mass transit
systems to make their own decisions
about the requirements sally jarromio
joins us now live from reid
international with what travelers who
were arriving to our airport today had
to say about the change sally
denise and brian this news is still
taking some time to process as you can
see right behind me here at harry reid
international there are still signs
reminding you to wear a mask while some
are for the new changes others have
mixed opinions
just being so comfortable with it at
first it was aggravating now and just
became a part of me without it it's like
what's going on again confusion among
travelers tuesday who recently learned
the mass mandate was dropped at harry
reid international randy davis flew in
from kentucky and is surprised how
quickly things change al allen is
visiting from colorado springs and
agrees i wore it on the airplane coming
out here
the majority of people didn't that i've
had all my shots i've had my two
boosters so i feel comfortable
the airport isn't the only place lifting
the mandate rideshare companies are too
about time daniel jordan drives for uber
he found out through the news and uber
email he is happy about it as is
another uber driver most people don't
want to win when they get in my car and
i tell them it's their choice we're just
going back to normancy and that's
where it should be i don't take the mask
off matter of fact normancy is cool
yes
now back out live some passengers tell
me they're still going to be wearing the
mask while on the plane just as a safety
precaution for now reporting live from
harry reid international sally jaramillo
live local now